en esta ocasión tenemos aquí a un
triángulo rectángulo donde su uno de sus
catetos vale
el otro vale ven y la hipotenusa vale c
y como es un triángulo rectángulo
nosotros sabemos cómo están relacionados
a b y c están relacionados con el
teorema de pitágoras que nos dice lo
siguiente que a cuadrada que a cuadrada
uno de los catetos elevado al cuadrado a
esto le sumamos a esto le sumamos b
cuadrada le sumamos b cuadrada esto nos
da igual es decir estamos sumando el
otro cateto elevado al cuadrado esto es
exactamente lo mismo que la hipotenusa
elevada al cuadrado de lujo y bueno lo
que quiero ver en este vídeo es cómo
puedo relacionar las funciones
trigonométricas con precisamente esta
expresión que tengo aquí esta expresión
del teorema de pitágoras y bueno para
esto lo primero que quiero hacer es
tomar una ángulo aunque no sea el ángulo
de 90 grados se me ocurre este de aquí y
le voy a poner el nombre
ok entonces recordemos que nos dice el
soca
el socket ahora lo que nos dice es
el seno es igual al cateto por esto
entre la hipotenusa cam lo que nos dice
es que el cose no es igual al cateto ya
centro entre la hipotenusa y todas todas
la tangente es igual al cateto opuesto
entre el cateto adyacente ahora si ya
tenemos el soca tú a qué te parece si lo
aplicamos a este mismo triángulo
rectángulo para ver a que llegamos el
seno del ángulo el seno el seno del
ángulo y bueno me voy a tomar este
ángulo en cuestión esto va a ser igual
al cateto opuesto que en este caso es b
al cateto opuesto que sven entre la
hipotenusa que en este caso es c / c
ok ahora pensemos en el coche no si yo
me fijo en el coche no en el coche no de
este ángulo teta aquí va a ser igual
bueno es el cateto yacente que en este
caso es am entonces va a ser am ya esto
lo voy a dividir entre la hipotenusa la
hipotenusa que vale c ahora cómo puedo
relacionar esta información que tengo
aquí del seno del coseno con este
teorema de pitágoras y esta relación que
tengo aquí bueno pues aquí tengo aa
cuadrada ave cuadrada y aquí tengo ave
jump
lo que me parece muy bueno sería elevar
a ambos lados del seno y del coseno al
cuadrado y que me va a quedar a ver si
lo hacemos me va a quedar que si yo
elevó esta parte seno elevado al
cuadrado de tam esta parte la estoy
elevando al cuadrado entonces esta parte
también la tengo que llevar al cuadrado
esto va a ser igual a b cuadrada entre
pse cuadrada ave cuadrada b cuadrada
/ cuadrada / se cuadrado ok y si hago lo
mismo con el coseno con el coche no voy
a llegar a lo siguiente que el coseno
cuadrado de este ángulo de este mundo
teta va a ser exactamente lo mismo que y
voy a elevar estos dos al cuadrado que a
cuadrada que a cuadrada entre pse
cuadrada entre pse cuadrada y bueno esto
para qué porque que te parece si ahora
sumamos el seno cuadrado y el coseno
cuadrado y voy a llegar algo muy
parecido a esta expresión si yo me tomo
ahora el seno cuadrado el seno cuadrado
de este ángulo ya éste le sumo le sumó
el coseno cuadrado de este ángulo el
coseno cuadrado de este ángulo bueno
pues esto va a ser exactamente lo mismo
que b cuadrada entre ese cuadrado esto
vale el seno cuadrado ok
b cuadrado entre entre ese cuadrado
entre pse cuadrado ok ya esto le voy a
sumar
voy a sumar el coste no elevado al
cuadrado del ángulo lo cual es lo mismo
que a cuadrada entre ese cuadrado es
decir a déjame tomar este color a
cuadrada ok entre ese cuadrado entre ese
cuadrado
sin embargo date cuenta que crea algo
muy importante tenemos el mismo
denominador por lo tanto podemos sumar
estas dos fracciones de una manera muy
sencilla el denominador se conservan que
es se cuadrada
ok mientras que la parte de arriba
solamente nos vamos a tomar la suma de b
cuadrada de b cuadrada más a cuadrada
más a cuadrada y porque estoy haciendo
esto porque yo sé cuánto vale de 4 adam
masa cuadrada b cuadrada masa cuadrada
por el teorema de pitágoras es
exactamente lo mismo que se cuadrada y
esto es muy importante ahora voy a
utilizar esta expresión que tengo aquí
porque entonces esto se puede reducir
esto es exactamente lo mismo que se
cuadra a cuadra damas b cuadrada s
cuadrada a cuadrada más b cuadrada
ok en tren se cuadrada y bueno se cuadra
en 13 cuadrada y es lo mismo que uno
entonces esto se va a uno a qué me
refiero con todo esto
aquí estoy llegando algo sorprendente si
nosotros tenemos el seno de un ángulo y
lo elevamos al cuadrado y después nos
tomamos el coseno de un ángulo y lo
elevamos al cuadrado esto va a ser
exactamente igual a uno y ya estoy
relacionando a las funciones
trigonométricas con una relación que
tiene que ver con el teorema de
pitágoras y justo
esta es la identidad de econométrica
pitagórica y lo padre de todo esto es
que solamente utilizando las
definiciones del soca tohá llegamos a la
identidad trigonométricas yo creo que es
la más importante de todas que nos dicen
que el seno el seno cuadrado de un
ángulo a esto le sumó a esto le sumó el
coseno cuadrado el cos en un cuadrado de
ese mismo ángulo y esto va a ser
exactamente igual exactamente igual y
llegamos
a 1 a 1 esta es la identidad
trigonométricas más importante que hay y
déjame ponerla con este color esta es la
más importante que hay y la acabamos de
encontrar utilizando la definición del
soca tohá y seguramente le vamos a decir
oye sal y pero yo no entiendo por qué
tanta fiesta por esta de identidad
trigonométricas pero puedes verlo así
ahora si te doy ya el seno de un ángulo
de aquí podemos despejar te vas a poder
obtener una manera muy sencilla el
coseno del ángulo o viceversa y bueno
todo esto lo hicimos en el círculo
trigonométrico pero justo esta es la
motivación para hablar del círculo
trigonométrico y sus definiciones